Cause I, I can't even, I don't even
feel alive and I'm out of breath.
That's what I get for being a musician.
I lose a pound a night on stage
sweating with Aerosmith. Right.
I'm up there with standing next
to fucking Joe Perry. Really?
The last of the real rock stars you,
you stood across from him.
It's a bad motherfucker. I don't know
if he was stolen is with you, but he's,
when I get text messages from him,
like, Holy Shit, I fucking the text.
And I saw him in the beginning
and I knew he was there. Well,
you something special. I knew he was
that. He's got a, he's got a recognizable,
there's like certain people that
have a sound, you know, and Joe has,
he absolutely has a sound, you
know, as a sound. Gary Clark Jr Ooh.
Like you hear Gary Clark Jr
Play Guitar. You Go, oh, okay.
That's a Gary Clark Jr riff. You know,
there's certain people that have a sound.
Joe Most certainly has a sound.
It's like he's expressing himself through
that guitar in a very recognizable way.
You know, you two together, man.
What a fucking combination that was
with his guitar and your voice and,
but here's, but here's, and here's
the trip. In the beginning, you know,
the first album, people who've
said, who sat on the second album,
good on a second album.
I kind of like that
peewee Herman Chocolatey
parking. Cause I want to sound
black. Oh fuck. I'm not stupid.
I get it. I wanted to put some
fucking soul soul in my voice.
I knew I had it and force
it out. No, no, no, no.
What I learned was, you know,
like from a Nat King Cole,
he's the kind of music I listen to
when I was a kid, when I met Natalie,
I walked up behind her and I went
chemo, chemo stairs, stair my,
my Ho Marum take a pump and soup,
bang, nip cap on. And Mitch Cameo,
I love you.
She went,
no one is song that ever to eat up.
My Daddy who said to dad passed obviously,
but way before.
But that's it.
Those are the records I listened to that
was not singing his best shit. And, um,
well,
here's what I wanted to sound.
I wanted to sound more like
Joe Perry was playing. Ah,
it's singing really sweet and Nice,
isn't it? Dream on sweet and Nice.
I kind of go, I kind of went there and
when we wrote a song on a waterbed,
you'll Perry and I were sitting
around smoking a big fatty and um,
Mark Lehman was there. He was our road
manager. And, and show goes Brownlow
parallel Mohan Barcelona alone.
Oh Man. [inaudible] anywhere near me.
Me and me, ma'am. Ma'Am, ma'am, ma'am.
[inaudible]
I'm looking at him and that was the
sentence he spoke to me and I said,
we all live on the edge of
town where we all live in.
And so Lou Brown people started calling
me and all do just a grin. And Sam,
I'm gotta move out. Goals hit him
moving in some saying he, she told,
he spoke to me and you I
answered, translated it. I, yeah,
I would listen to the bit,
we would sit around and we were jam.
That's what we did the best.
And we would create this music and I would
put the headphones on later cause I'm
the lyricist and I were in the melody.
I see when I heard Joe's band,
I thought I'm going to take my dad,
Vic Talerico who went to Julliard
in New York and a coping the Bronx,
56 10 Netherland Avenue,
you six g department and I grew up
under the piano and I listened to,
my dad would practice
every day on a Steinway.
So who lived between the notes show you
and saying I love you [inaudible] name's
Joe.
I just love Joe's fucking
love Perry fucking love.
You know he's my bro. You go eat yo,
what the fuck man? It's always been that.
So,
but anyway,
so I took my melody and you know what
I hear when I listened to him playing.
Whoa Shit.
So when you guys did your second
album and you did that little sort of
affectations that how you would
call it a new voice, did you,
after you heard it and you listened
to like people talking about it,
did you decide to change it
for the next album? Wow, I did.
Just go away for a minute, didn't
I? Yeah. I love it when I do that.
Yeah.
The,
the melody that I learned from my
dad and then listening to the music,
we listened to, you know, Dorsey and, uh,
Frank Sinatra and Nat King Cole and,
and then Janice Joplin and the Phillies
fugs who were the first ones to put on
the back of their album, uh,
lunatic vagina. That's who.
So who sang the song is 61,
the mothers of invention.
He's fucking bands. And I went, what?
So I thought sing and really like my
dad taught me in the notes and write on,
and you know, c, d, e f, g, a, B.
You don't have a fuck you
no wrong, wrong, wrong.
You've got to, not only that, but if
you don't put inflections into it,
there ain't no feeling.
And there ain't no meaning.
I got you lack,
I do last time Beta.
Whoops.
Right where he say it.
But you have to feel,
it can't be something you trying to feel.
It's gotta be something you actually feel.
Does that make sense? Yeah. But I think,
you know, Joe Hat's off to him, man,
the way he played his
guitar practice at night,
he'd fucking nod out and he'd be sitting
in his chair and the fucking chair,
the couch caught on fire to,
since I walked in with a pot of water and
he's laying there rooms full of smoke.
I went, Yo, what the fuck man getting,
he's playing this riff and we turned
it into a song and this kind of stuff
happens so much. And he did it
away to me. Fucking they obviously,
you know Tom Hamilton, du Du, Du,
Du, Du, Du, Du, Du, Du, Du, Du, Du,
Du Sui a motion. That's how
band comes together, you know?
And I can't tell you any other way than
that magic and every inch of the way,
the reason it doesn't feel like
I'm 70 and I don't feel the time,
and it feels like yesterday
we just started is because
every time I'm on stage,
I'm singing in those same fucking
songs again. Same way, same feeling,
same looking, same people,
different people, different people.
But I'm singing the same songs. Do you
know the guy that's looking, it's, anyway,
so to answer your question, second
album sounds a little bit more Raunchy,
more in tune with Joe's guitar. And I
think we found our sound second home,
third, fourth, fifth, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
We got it right. But it took,
that first album, had songs on it
like walking the dog because we were,
we ran out of songs with,
that was all we played in clubs.
I remember we had a contract, what are
we going to do? So we're moving out.
Then the guys would get stoned and drink
Boone's farm and I go, come on you guys.
We fucking wrote this song.
Fuck you. And flick the joint.
So I remember getting
pissed off walking out.
They hate me when I tell this story,
but I remember being really fucking angry
walking out to his piano and writing
one way street.
Um,
I don't play guitar and I wrote
about him and doing it. Um,
make it, don't break it
first of all in first album.
So some great shit because I
feel like, you know, in anger,
you know, I didn't know what to
do, but I just put a use that.
So I wrote a bunch of songs and
I think it lit everybody's fuse.
I think that Joe certainly lit mine.
Tom Hamilton is outtakes, as
he called him. Sweet emotion.
That's Tom Hamilton.